so first of all have you guys done camp
growing up at all and if not would you
want to
i never got to but kevin kevin you went
to camp right
yeah i did i went for three years in
wisconsin uh when i was
i guess a tween or a teen so being
believable 22 was a
completely new experience but a lot of
fun it was really fun for me i was like
i was avery you know my character's
supposed to know the ins and outs of
camp and
will's supposed to be you know the fish
out of water i was like the genuine fish
out of water i was like what does that
do what is that so
heck yeah i would i would go to camp i
would love to be like a camp counselor i
feel like i'd kill it i'd love it
oh yes did you guys have uh rebellious
years growing up at all
not loud i mean i feel like i
i was a troublemaker for sure i was so
energetic
i that might have been an explanation
for how i got into performing
yeah but i wouldn't call myself anything
beyond a troublemaker
our moms are watching like no i think we
were i think we were raised by some
some loving families and i was working
so much of it so
uh even if i dared to give an eye roll
for a half a second which i never did i
would have been in deep trouble so
yeah um favorite scenes to film
any of the musical numbers are honestly
so much fun i mean you'll see
watching watching the film they're so
big and elaborate and for me i love
music so it was like
checking things off of my bucket list
that i'd had for so long
um so those scenes were a blast and and
i do there's a there's a scene on the
road
um between kevin and i and uh that scene
in the movie is is really special
and uh and was a lot of fun a blast
you can't go wrong with the musical
numbers they're definitely the most fun
to film
uh yeah at the halfway point of the film
it takes a dramatic turn which a lot of
people probably don't expect
but some of those great scenes that i i
really enjoyed filming were the more
dramatic ones
i had started in theater and stage
productions and a little bit of drama
and i had taken a break for that to do
some comedy some multi-cam half-hour
stuff
uh so be being able to revisit that uh
for the first time in a while
it was really special to me and i just
love being able to
delve in with these emotional characters
and these emotional scenes
the road sequence was one i loved uh the
conversation between sean and will
at the stage um and
obviously some of the stuff with avery
yeah
he's like some of the stuff with bayley
not all of it
some of it was pretty good it was fine
well it's the dramatic stuff did you
guys
have instant chemistry because you can
see it on film was it something that
when you met
you guys just started laughing and
having a good time or did it build while
you were on set
yeah i mean i had met kevin uh years
prior actually
so uh we had met each other when we were
kind of you know babies and so getting
to
step into this world was so exciting to
kind of see each other and now be like
oh my gosh like we're adults now
like we love each other in this movie
and like you know we're gonna have to
like
you know so much of it was so different
and so fun but um
i would say you know our our whole cast
truly did become so close i mean we we
still talk to this day and
uh my bestie in the movie you know cat
she's like we talk all the time and
i think just every single day especially
four weeks of dance rehearsals when
we're all
thrown into such an unfamiliar
environment and we all had to lean on
each other i mean that's
that's destined to kind of you know
force you to create that that chemistry
and that love within each other so
there was a whole lot of trust and a lot
of inside jokes and a lot of giggles and
we had a great time
yeah the coolest parts of the film was
just the chemistry not only between
avery and will
which i was so excited to develop with
bayley uh with this film
uh but just the chemistry between all
the characters they all have
independent relationships with each
other and each relationship has a
different dynamic
and in a way we kind of fall in love
with the five characters as a whole
as much as we fall in love with each one
of them and
it's really hard to accomplish that in a
film i got to give it up to our casting
director beverly holloway too she did a
really nice job
putting that together